vita means life it means to be a vita
islander it means to be a part of a cult
following that believed in this little
machine more than the makers themselves
did and i
was not one of them
cue
the booze
but that doesn't mean i wasn't always
curious i just missed the boat to vita
island a place in which many people are
still abandoned to this day everyone has
left vita island the people on vita
island are trapped on vita island so i
might be 10 years late but better late
than never to see what this thing is all
about the people love so damn much
this is
10 years later
with the vita
first my journey with the vita begins
with not having one but thankfully i
knew it again
hey
what are you doing with this uh i'm
making uh a 10-year retrospective from a
dude he's never played with all right i
love you bye-bye
[Music]
when i finally got it in my hands i was
hoping to boot it up to a bunch of
exclusive vita games i couldn't play
anywhere else i did not know powerstone
was on this dude
instead i was greeted with mostly ps1
games like metal gear solid final
fantasy vagrant story in castlevanias
there were the usual games i was
familiar with like danganronpa and
virtue's last reward but then there was
also persona 4 golden but why play some
beloved game like persona when i could
play the real sony flagships like
uncharted and killzone and
i admit now
that was my first mistake i booted up
uncharted golden abyss and it certainly
looked the part but it was also
accompanied with what felt like forced
touch controls and aiming with the back
and gyro that made me feel like an idiot
kill zone was basically the exact same
experience except the shooting wasn't
the most comfortable thing for me on
that size device i ended up doing the
claw thing quite a bit to hit the other
buttons and yeah just
i mean they certainly follow through
with that high production value sony
stamp of approval but i couldn't help
feel that these were being muzzled by
vita's gimmicky features a lot of which
had me holding and using the vita in
ways that just felt incredibly unnatural
i knew somewhere underneath these funky
controls that there were good games i
just didn't have the patience to find
them and i mean how could i have not
i've never had this thing i never owned
this thing i just knew it had
these dual touch screens and all these
other features and functions so it was
only natural that i wanted to see what
those first-party sony developers that
are so prestigious and what they do
could do with so many
you know fun and touchy
thingama dudes
they look beautiful for what it's worth
[Music]
it wasn't until long that i naturally
just found myself turning to the games i
already knew on the device stuff like
power stone and tekken 6 and in the
process
continued to neglect persona 4 golden
despite it being installed just ready to
go staring me right in the eyes i admit
now
that is my second mistake in the matter
of days the vita had found a place at
the end of my desk where i began to
collect dust while i played other games
on my switch
one of them ironically a popular visual
novel that saw its american debut on the
vita the house and fatima ghana
my first impressions of this beloved
device at least right out of the box
were far from
enticing but i knew that what i had seen
was only a breath of what it had to
offer i knew that i was getting a very
narrow lens into this so i needed to
know more i needed the full picture i
didn't even know this thing's history
honestly the vita came out here in the
states in february 2012 somewhere
between the release of the 3ds and the
wii u and well i chose
the things on either side of the vita
with only one of those things
actually
doing okay out of the
full roster of that stuff sony's mission
after the incredibly successful psp was
to meld big budgeted game experiences
into the handheld and with it for some
reason packed in
was a bunch of features it had some
novel stuff like having dual analog
sticks an oled screen
in gyromotion it also had outward and
inward facing cameras and for some
reason not just a front
but a back touch screen too
still at first when it came out it was
pretty successful despite the gimmicks
it showed a promising prospect for its
future like at first yeah maybe most
people didn't understand why i needed
two touchscreens and i'm sure the back
touch screen also boosted the cost of it
being made but additionally you had to
use a proprietary ps vita memory card
which was a hidden cost for owners and
they were expensive
[Music]
while it sold okay in japan
here in the states sales began to slow
down real fast after the console's
release and a lot of the heavy hitting
studios decided to move on for the
device including its maker
sony only two years after its release
sony pivoted to try giving it multiple
uses
rather than more games like giving it
remote play for the ps4 and pstv which
was a companion device to play vita
games on your tv
the switch before the switch except you
didn't dock it still pretty novel i i
give them credit
they were like a little ahead of the
curve there
in fact 2014
was the last time the console got a
major first party release which was
freedom wars sony's answer to the
absence of monster hunter on the device
which had seen it's it's uh
that franchise live
live prosperly is that a word live
fruitfully on the 3ds instead
so when the ubisofts and eas and sony
stepped out the indies stepped in and
games like ali ali hotline miami and fez
suddenly found a new home on this thing
and the people who bought it and loved
it were now tasked with carrying its
legacy despite all of its major support
abandoning them and thus the vita
islanders
were born it's over the ship has sailed
everyone has left vita island the people
on vita island are trapped on vita
island while doing research i kept
coming across the hashtag aveda
islanders the hashtag spawned from the
vedas number one fan greg kind of funny
miller the king of the veda at least
that's how i view him
he's because he just loves that thing
and he'll tell you that he loves it
he'll
he'll make sure you know
you're where you where he's where you
stand with him when you haven't played
it
i would know greg i'm sorry but i've
never
played the vita until now and what a
surprise where were you 10 years ago
that's when we needed you you all come
around now and you're like oh it's a
great persona machine oh freedom war
seemed really cool oh my god this is
where i should have been playing hotline
miami the whole time you want a pat on
the back you want everybody to show up
watch your little video read your little
feature because 10 years you find jesus
later it doesn't help the vita is dead
and it's because of you oh
oh the steam deck's coming wow
i can play indies in the [ __ ]
giant game gear the vita was better than
that and you knew it was
i got
uh
i got tear away
tearaway's real good tearaway's a real
good one yeah clearly people were very
passionate about this thing and i
started to fear that i would regret at
least not trying to understand that
so
i picked it back up i began playing it
constantly in meetings while i pretended
to listen to jesse while she rambled
about playstation all-stars well we
can't be super smash brothers so you
can't knock people off the stage so
hitting people built up a meter i even
took it with me on the stationary bike
while i played gravity russian hotline
miami then i finally came around to tear
away the first game that really showed
the potential for all of vida's gimmicks
but in the best way possible it was the
only thing i played that really
demonstrated a bespoke experience only
available to the vita
[Music]
but there was still one last game on
this device that lingered in the shadows
installed and ready to go at any moment
that i knew i would have to play at one
point to truly understand what it is
that makes this console so special to so
many people so i finally booted up
persona 4 golden
playing persona 4 golden was the first
time i felt that i could really put
myself in the shoes of someone who this
device meant a lot to i'm only a few
hours in at this point but there's been
a string of murders there's this
whole concept of the midnight channel
like looking into your tv at midnight to
see possible next victim as well as this
over arching theme of a big corporate
business coming in and hurting
independent businesses around it and
like how all these things are playing
into each other i should have played
this first this is very much
a kurt thing murders detectives spooky
stuff at
midnight and you're right greg this is a
wonderful persona machine and it's not
so much just persona 4 specifically but
it's when i began really seeing what the
vita offered that other devices just
didn't at the time i picked this thing
up so fixated on trying to understand
all its features and bells and whistles
convinced i'd find some justification
for all of it but i never did but that's
because from the start i was looking in
the wrong place considering that this
game wasn't really available anywhere
else at the time i can really
imagine someone losing hours and hours
and hours to this game on this device
in their hands and
i can really
kind of understand why
this would have been
special to someone why this thing would
have been important i'm getting it it's
clicking it's clicking
and that's when it really sunk in that
this thing upon its release really
didn't know what it was but its identity
in the end was informed by its players
when this thing first came out it was
supposed to be sony's answer to aaa
gaming in the mobile space but in
reality it became the indie buddy the
ps1 pale the go-to machine for
non-triple-a titles
something that the switches for a lot of
people today
including me
you
emails interrupting
[Music]
i don't regret waiting all this time to
have played the vita um in fact if i'm
being completely honest after i finish
persona 4 gold then i don't know if i'll
ever touch this again unless someone
sends me a copy of freedom wars or touch
my katamari
then maybe i'll consider it i'm not some
vida islander all of a sudden besides i
don't think anyone that's on vita island
would want me there now
anyways but i'm glad i got to spend time
with this thing and see it beyond
what was there at face value what was
there beyond what the aaa
corner of the game industry gave it i
got to see a glimpse into
into something into a device that was
held up
by
not the big leagues but the indies by
the players and that is what matters
like that's what men are looking at i
know they're all i know you're bitter
and grumpy greg that i wasn't there from
the start but now i can at least take a
step back and understand why for so many
people
veda
means life
[Music]
also thank you tomorrow hussein for
letting me borrow this
it means a lot
[Music]